je cultive ma ressemblance avec une star
avec cultive je cultive ma ressemblance
[Applaudissements]
on va voir si vous soufflez de vos
émissions des thèmes que vous avez
traités à une Thomas on va faire une
interview Laurent fait ou à faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense pas Catherine que ce soit une
très bonne idée d'avoir mis Laurent
Baffie et d'armoire
attention Évelyne Thomas vous me dites
fait ou pas fait je suis roux et alors
je suis fou amoureux de mon chien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous verrez les gens vous embrasser et
vous aurez des pluies de pétales de
roses attention je me moque de mon
hygiène
la [__] de mon mari a un goût
déjà fait
je fais des choses que personne ne fait
avec la [__] de mon mari qui a un goût
pas très précise
je cultive ma ressemblance avec une star
je cultive ma ressemblance
je cultive ma ressemblance avec moi-même
non
je communique avec l'au-delà je
communique avec l'au-delà mais c'est lui
qui paye
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu